fünf Tage nach Verkündung der Teil
Mobilisierung wächst in Russland der
Widerstand in der Teilrepublik Dagestan
etwa weigern sich Männer in den Krieg zu
ziehen Frauen stellen sich schützen vor
sie die Polizei geht mit Warnschüssen
dazwischen
wer kann versuchten diesen Tagen noch
wegzukommen aus Russland Staus nach
Finnland nach Georgien in die Mongolei
Flüge sind kaum noch zu kriegen doch in
Russland gibt es auch Zustimmung für
putinskurs
ich bin bereit für die Mobilmachung ich
warte auf die einen Berufung das dient
dem Schutz unseres Heimatlandes wir
kämpfen gegen Faschisten
das stört mich nicht wenn es notwendig
ist
bislang konnten die Menschen das was in
der Ukraine passiert weit wegschieben
aber die Teilen Mobilisierung hat das
schlagartig geändert
viele Befürworter unterstützen den Krieg
nur unter der Bedingung dass er irgendwo
weit weg ist und sie nicht persönlich
betrifft ihre Meinung wird sich nicht an
einem Tag ändern ihre Meinung über den
Krieg und Putin wird sich erst innerhalb
von Wochen oder Monaten ändern
in jakutskreisen mutige Frauen die
Polizei ein
und landen im Gefangenentransporter
und in Sankt Petersburg kennen die
Sicherheitskräfte mal wieder keine Gnade
brutal schlagen sie gestern auf der
monstranten ein das harte Vorgehen kein
Zufall die Brutalität hat eine neue
Dimension erreicht das fällt besonders
auf
das Ziel Demonstrationen gegen Putin
gegen die teilmobilisierung schon im km
ersticken wer hier hinkommt braucht viel
Mut
gerne würden wir mit den Demonstranten
oder Demonstranten sprechen warum sie
hier sind doch wer mit den Medien
spricht und Interviews gibt dem droht
die sofortige Festnahme auch das ist neu
in den letzten Jahren konnte man zusehen
wie der Raum der Meinungsfreiheit in
Russland immer kleiner wurde und jetzt
ganz zu verschwinden droht als wir am
Mittwoch bei den Protesten in Moskau
drehen interviewen wir einen
Demonstranten
unsere Leute dürfen nicht sterben unsere
Mütter haben schon
die Polizei macht kurzen Prozess ifgeni
wird festgenommen später erfahren wir er
muss 15 Tage in Haft der Vorwurf
Ungehorsam gegen die rechtmäßige
Anordnung eines Polizeibeamten und es
droht die direkte Einberufung von der
Zelle weiter an die Front plötzlich ist
Putins sogenannte spezialoperation in
der russischen Gesellschaft angekommen
und viele spüren jetzt dass in Russland
noch harte Zeiten drohen